[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today to this
question comes from Addie in
Oklahoma she says I'm writing because I
have a bit of doubt about this situation
my mom wants to be a co-signer for me to
be able to buy a property through an FHA
loan since I will be an firsttime home
buyer I will be living in the property
but it will be divided and the other
side will be rented I was pre-approved
for 325 ,000 my mom and the realtor we
are working with are telling me that we
that we have to put offers on properties
at full asking price but I'm concerned
about this I'm 23 years old I only make
36,000 o I only make $366,000 a year as
a medical assistant and currently owe
$10,000 on student loans should I wait
before I make such a big investment yes
yes yes yes okay let's look at some red
flags here um number one you make
$36,000 $36,000 a year that's quite low
that's half of the national average yeah
that's that's quite quite low and you're
wanting to buy a quarter of a million
dollar house over a quarter a million
doll house
$325,000 the reason you feel nervous and
the reason that you feel like you can't
breathe because it's literally like John
deloney would say it's your body telling
you there's something wrong and when
there's something wrong don't ignore it
let's look at what's wrong and you can
see what's what the problem is here you
understand that the only way that you're
getting this loan is your mom would be
signing for that means if you can't get
a loan on your own it means that all of
the loan companies know this is a bad
idea you can't pay and the only way that
we mitigate some of this risk is we
bring on someone who we think might be
able to pay when you won't be able to
make the payment and in that case this
would be your mother um and she probably
thinks that she's is being sweet for
saying oh I'll sign for you I want you
to have this home but that's it's a
horrible idea because you know and I
know that you're not making a lot of
money you still have
debt and the chances of you not being
able to make this payment is high not to
mention there's the renting side about
this it sounds like you are both
dependent on a renter to live on the
other side in order to make this payment
which again is Crea
a lot of risk yeah this is a mess Addie
don't do it this is a mess and let's add
one more element to this it's okay
you're going to be a homeowner yeah
you're 23 it's okay you're going to make
it okay but your mom has been
controlling this entire conversation
yeah and maybe it's time that you just
said Mom you know I love you and I'm
just not going to do this right now and
that's going to do a lot of things for
you and your mom one is is she's not
going to get to control you with the
purchase she and the realtor are telling
you what to do do you not hear that it
was very clear in the language that you
used you're you're being treated like a
little girl like your mom's pretty she
may mean well but she's Pretty stinking
controlling here and she loves the fact
she needs to
cosign she loves the fact that you are
dependent upon her cuz now she gets to
tell you what to do even more mhm so you
need to break free of mom
Mommy needs to be a grownup and uh Addy
needs to be a grownup yeah because what
Happ to be separated from Mommy and
enjoy mommy as a peer not as a
controlling mother of a 23-year-old
treating you like she like you're 13
you're not making a decision in this
entire thing every one of these
decisions are being made by someone else
and pushed upon you mhm you need to
stiff arm this back step back breathe
get you a nice little apartment a great
life and let all those people go do
their little lives and then when you get
ready to buy a house you'll be in a
position to buy a house yeah cuz only
only two scenarios come of this if she
went through it's bad it's all bad if
she doesn't make that payment a her
mom's lording it over her I it's she her
mom's her mom's going to tell her when
she can take vacation cuz she co-s on
the laan I'm telling you I smell control
freak a mile away and I and I I've got a
good nose for it